so toothbrush commercials sometimes
one would say maybe they could be a
little boring but when it comes to kevin
hart who always makes people laugh
it's a great way to sort of show off a
smile so what's your plan
how are you how are you making this all
happen with this commercial
i think by just being real you know i
think sometimes when you
overdo it and you oversell uh you step
into a place of just
what else has been done and what has
been seen
uh if you haven't me and amy is actually
in love with a product
so you allow me to be me and that's
personable
that's funny that's charismatic um and
and at the same time get a message
across a message of why
and a message of what makes this special
so there's an amazing opportunity not
just for myself but for the product at
hand
um all the makings of what i would like
to call a great relationship than
opportunity
that's amazing so a good truth brush is
a multi-tasker
kind of just like you i see those two
things in common what else do you and
the toothbrush have in common
i like that i like the multi-tasker and
the toothbrush
uh being a multi-tasker as well hard
workers there you go
and i i look at the bruce toothbrush as
a hard worker
you know it uh it can it can achieve
several different tasks
and and that's something that i take
pride in as well so
that's our that's our common trade i
like it
yeah definitely you are a multitasker
for sure so what made you decide to
to um be a part of this company
it's it's a startup and it's a canadian
company what drew you to this project uh
it's different you know i think the the
biggest and best thing here is just
what i pride myself on doing in my life
and my career
and that's making people smile so you
know the energy that comes from rafting
the energy
that comes from people smiling is one
that's contagious so
to be able to attach yourself to a brand
that's uh
that's in the beginning stage of
possibly growing and and becoming who
knows and what
for me it was a great opportunity uh it
all goes hand in hand
if if i can't tell a story about it if
it's not authentic to me
to what i represented to what i do that
is not something i can touch
but i smile i smile a lot uh you know
i had a cavity in my life which means
so are you the guy who's had lots of
cavities because i've had a lot
never never i'm very serious hand on the
bible i've never had a cavity in my life
but i don't eat sweets either i'm not a
i'm not a sugar rat
ever no candy no candy no cakes salt i
mean
i like smoked chips yeah okay
well that's good so then yes that makes
you the perfect candidate for this for
this job for sure
it has to fit that be a relationship
which there is so
it's a great opportunity once again yeah
for sure so you're filming in canada
and i know you're good friends with the
rock who is like sort of an honor
like a canadian um and you're kind of
stepping on his turf right now anything
you want to say to him
about that oh i don't know why you guys
still claim him
you know i don't i don't i've never
heard him say anything about
canada and you know i'm with him a lot
so i don't know if you guys know that
but
it's like you're staying true to a
person that doesn't really talk about
you much
me on the other hand i'm always talking
about canada
how amazing the people are here uh
how much fun i have when i go the food
you know it's just so much to do open
arms
welcoming i'm the one that's always
being vocal about that but i've never
heard him do the same so
i'm not trying to start anything i'm not
trying to create a problem between
canada and him i'm just saying that
maybe
he's not carrying the same amount of
love that you guys are whatever that's
not
not for me to get into once again so we
maybe need to rethink this
i think is what we're saying look if not
that's not what i'm here to do
i'm just at the same time pointing an
arrow in a direction that maybe you guys
should start looking
i like it you're also new dad again
congratulations how is it different this
time for you
uh four man baby number four you know
when you just realize that it's time now
uh
it's time to time to pack it up
yeah time to get rid of them i'm not
talking about the testies it's time to
throw them on the roof i'm
i'm done yeah this is jersey because
five's a great number
i i don't i don't know why i'm saying
that i don't i have no control
it's whatever it's whatever my wife
wants i i can act as if i have control
but
i don't you can you can talk about
it but it's the most beautiful thing in
the world when it's all
in front of your face so you know being
able to look at
four kids now uh a living room full
of kids and know that we have a
on-growing and ongoing family
that's going to live on and that last
name is going to continue to go
uh when it's all said and done for me
that's the best thing in the world so
i just try to do what i can while i can
and um
involves one more baby to get to that
number five and so be it but the house
is definitely louder
it's louder
yeah for sure we only have two and i'm
telling you two dogs two kids and i'm
like
we're good it's good all right well
that's the case i got six cause we got
two dogs too
so oh yeah that's a lot yeah it's a
whole lot
so now my husband is gets the pleasure
of
directing you today which is where all
the worlds collide
um be straight up with me what
is what kind of director is he uh like
he's anybody that is uh
not only aware of the day but love
to to move at a rapid pace
and be efficient while doing that i'm
i'm a fan so uh you know this is uh
it was supposed to be like an eight to
ten hour day which is ridiculous like i
would never
do yeah and getting it done in like
three and a half hours and that's
because
we had a great conversation on the phone
and he's doing his job of
meeting the brand's needs and at the
same time getting his crew to be on
par and page with what he wants to get
shots he wants so i would say he's doing
good
i i have no nothing bad to say only look
at that
running through the day because of you
guys i was waiting to see
i was i don't know why i was going to
hear like maybe choose loud
or slurp drinks funny like nothing
that's great i got nothing but good a
little mean to people
i heard them cussing out a couple people
that's none of my business once again
i'm not here
to start anything that's not what i'm
here for
you know and maybe that's you know maybe
that's what you guys do in your
household which also
[Laughter]
i don't know what and that's not why i'm
here but i'm saying
nice he's he's honestly very nice man
very cool guy
down to earth guy and uh i think we're
lucky to have him he's doing doing a
great job
yeah well we're just so lucky to have
you here in canada and i'm so grateful
you took the time on your lunch break to
do this
you're a special man and thanks for
making us laugh all these years and
thanks so much for today thank you
that's very nice of you
and uh i don't know how you guys you
know do it
here in canada but in the states where
we find out that people aren't saying
nice things about
us you know we put it all over the news
or
our outlets so i don't know if you guys
want to put like
a picture of dj's face okay
and does he love canada or not right and
start a conversation i don't know well i
think i've made my choice
like i think i i know where i i live now
so i'm good i'm part i'll be part of the
campaign
so i'm there good good good
once again like i said not starting
anything just kind of out there to see
where no one does it
okay have a great night and thanks again
you